vous êtes obligé faut me le dédicacer ah
bah ouais voilà c'est ça vous connaissez
Véronique évidemment oui tell surprise
je savais pas qu'elle venait ce soir
j'avoue alors nous avez rien dit si
Véronique est avec nous ce soir et
Véronique refait de la télé et on parle
santé Véronique aujourd'hui ça c'était
cé un pour temp pour toi et gym parce
qu'évidemment la gym ne t'a jamais
jamais quitté jamais incroyable ça
jamais 40 ans plus de 40 ans d'ailleurs
43 ans 40 ans 43 ans de de de gym
évidemment on se souvient de toi
aujourd'hui tu interviens avec cette
chronique dans le magazine santé qui est
présenté par Marina carrer dans C son
France 5 depuis la rentrée chronique sur
le thème sport et senior et je suis très
très heureuse d'être dans cette émission
qui est une belle émission j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration en plus pour Marina carè d'
cause donc quand elle m'a proposé j'ai
immédiatement j'ai même pas réfléchi une
seconde donc je suis un petit peu
spécialiste des seniors comp tenu de mon
âge avancé donc c'est ma ma spécialité
mais oui alors mais je sais pas il faut
la su sur les réseaux sociaux vonique
parce que c'est incroyable d'abord elle
fait encore grand éc je te demand pas de
le faireci mais c'est incroyable et tu
donnes des cours de gym tous les jours
tous les jours des cours de Gy en fait
j'ai actualité qui est très très
condensée je donne des cours tous les
matins des femmes quelques hommes qui me
suivent depuis des années des années des
années et ce sont tout des
se mais c'est toi ah je vous promet que
c'est moi pret que c'est moi la doublure
on au j'ai une doublure qui me su j'ai
une doublure c'est bien toi non voilà
donc je c'est toujours un bonheur de
savoir qu'on va donner de l'énergie et
du bonheur à des gens qui viennent à
vous pour prendre un cours prendre un
cours de gym c'est Barban et je suis
bien élevé en disant Barban donc si vous
ne trouvez pas la bonne personne qui
vous donne l'envie d'avoir envie de
prendre ce cours comme tu disais Johnny
alidé et bien c'est wallou vous allez
yer 3 mois toi dans ton petit club tu
m'as dit j'y vais j'y vais pas bah très
rarement ben ça se voit he non non tu es
parfait mais il faut absolument
s'entretenir quel que soit notre âge
quel que soit notre âge je m'occupe des
seniors donc par exemple dans les les
villabes au soleil qui sont des gens qui
ont entre 80 et 102 ans oh là Gy ans ils
font de la gym mais comment c'est Fab
attendsends attendsendsends 2 secondes
tu fais faire quoi à je vais t'expliquer
disoi j'ai fa j'ai mis au point une
technique pour que des personnes âgées
puissent s'entretenir dans leur fauteuil
alors c'est souvent les fauteuils
d'handicapé ça peut être dans dans son
fauteuil voilà ça voilà là vous êtes à
villab au soleil la semaine dernière à
La Rochelle et la moyenne d'âge des gens
mais c'est impressionnant c'est
extraordinaire donc quand il y a des
résultats moi ça me motive bien
évidemment et et enfin je sais pas je
trouve que c'est tellement naturel quand
on a un truc il faut le donner faut
partager et il faut le donner bravo mais
quelle énergie énergie
énergie
alors pour ceux qui ne souviennent pas
moi j'étais je me souviens moi j'ai
grandi avec toi c'est ça dimanche matin
un bébé tutais un bébé je me souviens
très bien mais attendez c'est incroyable
quand même c'était 12 millions de
téléspectateursouro 12 millions et 14
millions les les fêtes de fin d'année
Jama fait Mo Dav vonique c'était
ça
atttion
[Musique]
ou non on connait tous la musique hein
on connait tous la musique enc
aujourd'ui on est d'accord dans la rue
les gens qui me croisent c'est
automatique coucou
Touty incroyable de 82 à 86 sur Antenne
2 à l'époque et voilà le dimanche matin
ça duré une trentaine de minutes 12
millions de téléspectateurs et parmi et
parmi les invités que tu as eu il y a eu
Bernard ta entre autres ah oui entre
autres Bernard c'est ley oh allez
allez-y allez-y on se relâche pas c'est
pas le moment allez on B un
peu de il est meilleur que nous
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais c'est énorme
magorme d'ailleurs tuas vu la série la
série sur sur Bernard taille sur sur
Netflix j'ai pas vu la série parce que
j'ai pas Netflix ah voilà ça c'est une
bon question elle elle nous disait qu'il
avait mis ses abis oui il estabi avec
mes fringues sur les vêtements et rouge
et et vert parce qu'en fait quand il est
arrivé sur le plateau nous on était dans
ces couleurs là avec Davina et lui est
arrivé avec sa femme Dominique qui est
une amie en jogging bleu marine nou gris
je sais plus il a dit mais attends mais
je c'est pas possible il faut que je
sois habillé comme elle j'ai qu slim
tiette dans notre loge on a plein de
vêtements un peu larges pour justement
faire le grand écart et il s'est habillé
intégralement avec mes vêtements ah
c'est énorme c'est énorme donc ça ce
sont tes vêtements qui portent ou madame
c'est énorme
vous pourtant pas la même taille mais
non mais làdans tu sais les pantalons en
plastique large et tout et et Davina tu
encore des lien avec elle qu'est-ce
qu'elle est devenue Davina va très bien
elle vit dans un monastère elle est
nonbouddhiste depuis une vingtaine
d'années on est toujours en contact
évidemment rien à voir avec avant
puisque on on était nonstop ensemble et
elle va très bien elle su très
admirative de ce qu'elle fait elle a un
joli parcours elle fait des des stages
de sophrologie de enfin de plein plein
de choses de yoga et les gens viennent
la voir de partout et son monastère est
magnifique donc c'est très c'est on est
opposé c'estàdire que tu prends Davina
tu me prends moi ce qu'elle aime je
déteste ce que j'aime je déteste j'aime
un restaurant le déteste on est l'osé to
comment vous êtes rencontré comment vous
êes rencontré comment ça match cette
histoire dans un cours de danse un jour
très brièvement France gade avec qui
j'étais très ami m'a dit il paraît qu'il
y a une nana qui donne des cours elle
est odieuse veut pas qu'on aille voir un
cours de danse il faut que le professeur
soit un peu sec donc on y a été c'était
Dav qui é absolument génialissime et on
on on on a travaillé beaucoup beaucoup
avec elle et un jour elle m'a dit est-ce
que tu veux pas faire un concours de
chorégraphie avec moi en Suisse on est
parti le faire c avec Claude Bessy et
Serge liard qui aujourd'hui aurait 300
ans j'ai l'impression que je parle comme
mon j' vais 100 ans et et puis voilà et
de fil en aigule on a dit on devrait
donner des cours et ça s'est passé comme
ça mais c'est toujours des trucs de
hasard moi je marche beaucoup avec le
cœur le le il y a que ça qui m'intéresse
dans la VI et là c'était voilà un coup
de cœur Dam mais pourquoi Jim ton s'est
arrêté parce que moi j'ai pas connu ça
dans mon j'aurais aimé m'exciter devant
ma télé aussi j'ai pas pu le faire fais
les replay mais je suis obligé d'aller
dans les archives de l'Institut national
d'audiovisuel franchement non mais tuas
tu as pas vu la douche bah non j'ai pas
vu la douche les
images maintenant les images oui en a
tout tu vas tu vas nous expliquer
voniquece l'histoire l'histoire quand
même DEES
images res l'histoire de ces images
comment ça s'est fait parce que
l'histoire est absolument incroyable
aujourd'hui ça passe plus bah là on va
en
prison on était en train de tourner dans
un gymnase il faisait très très très
très chaud et la clim a pété et notre
réalisateur Michel Hermand au cas parce
dans le temps les car régies étaient
dans la rue n' plus rien à voir avec ça
il a dit les filles un petit cou de
maquillage je fais une coupure d'un
quart d'heure et moi j'ai répondu dans
le micro génial je vais prendre une
douche glacée et il m'a répondu je viens
filmer je tis pas cap il est venu avec
une caméra à l'épaule il y a pas de son
il y a rien il y a pas de lumière et
nous a filmé toutes les deux dans la
douche en train de se
boucher vraiment histoire offici ça t'a
pas dérangé ah pas du tout qu pourquoi
ça me dérange je sais pas pourquoi ça te
dérangeit tour du
monde danger je sais
Pasut tout le monde a les ses à l'air
sur une plage vous AZ une très belle
[Rires]
doubl Ann ça a duré des années
effectivement pu ça s'est arrêté
pourquoi 6 ça a duré l'émission elle a
duré 6 ans avec un nom de de redif mais
c'était un truc c'était une aventure
passionnante l'émission elle marchait
tellement bien qu'on nous disait où
est-ce que vous voulez aller tourner al
on disait bah la montagne au bord de la
mer oui alors parce que d'abord c'était
Pascal brgot la productrice et quià un
moment donné on on attribuit des des des
des enveloppes pour les émissions la NRE
elle marchait mais tellement bien que
cet argent a été dans les autres
émissions que produisait pas C brgot et
nous on disait bonjour les amis joyeux
Noël on était le 4 août donc toutes les
émissions passé en redif c'était un
bazar mais un bazar donc on a dit on va
faire un petit arrêt et quand quand on
fait un arrêt à la télé ça ne reprend
jamais c'est connu il y a plus il y a
plus d'émission comme ça c'est vrai que
c'est c'est une émission presque culte
qui est ultra moderne on voit VO matin
non mais oui mais pas peut-être pas
aussi sexy peut-être pas aussi là c'est
vra non non non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est avec c'est deux personnages comm
ça on était dans les années 80 c'est pas
du tout la même histoire pas du tout la
même histoire mais en revanche le
programme a été exporté à l'étranger au
Maroc je crois on est parti au Maroc ça
c'est une aventure incroyable on a été
sollicité par le directeur d'une grande
chaîne 2e internationale en nous disant
j'aimerais bien que vous fassiez votre
émission mais au Maroc on a dit banco on
y a été et moi j'aiété un peu arculon en
disant oh là là au Maroc ils vont nous
filmer avec une petite Mazda sur
l'épaule et on est arrivé dans un truc
mais exceptionnel d'ailleurs tous les
gens étaient formés par TF1 et cetera et
ça a été une aventure mais de dingue on
ne pouvait plus sortir de l'hôtel quand
on tournait les les gens mais c'était un
truc de de ouf ils avaient le ils ont le
culte de l'amitié sont des gens
extrêmement chaleureux et gentils et
c'était mais incroyable on était dans un
ascenseur avec Davina très brièvement et
le tournage était terminé et je dis à
Davina ah c'est génial on embrasse notre
réalisateur on lui dit on va enfin aller
dans les Soues ça faisait une semaine
qu' tournait pardon qu'ournit comme des
dingues et on prend l'ascenseur on était
à la Mamounia et à l'époque il y avait
un liftier va plus y avoir maintenant et
on dit ah c'est génial on va dans les
Souques et le type il s'est retourné il
a dit jamais de ta vie tu vas dans les
sou il y a tous les gens dehors qu'
disent Veroni
Davina c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
cé
pas c'est énorme C his Véronique une
question une question encore Véronique
c'est Miry dark en fait qui qui vous a
tendu la main l'histoire est magnifique
vous avez travaill pour pour Mireille
dark vous avez travaillé aussi pour pour
Alain Delon 18 ans 18 ans 18 ans
Mireille était vraiment ma sœur elle m'a
considéré toujours comme sa petite sœur
c'est elle qui est venue me chercher
j'étais j' arrivis d'Angleterre j'avais
17 ans je crois elle est venu me
chercher en me disant cherche une fille
comme toi bien dégourdie je pars tourner
un film la grande sauterelle au Liban
est-ce que tu es libre est-ce que tu
connais des amis j'ai dis non les amis
regarde c'est moi c'est moi elle m'a dit
non tu as pas compris je parle dans une
semaine et j'étais au test chef
responsable des têtes couronnées chez
Kita donc il a fallu le faire Gobber que
je partais et ça s'est très bien passé
et j'ai passé 50 ans d'amitié avec elle
et avec unind deelon toujours
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment il font
partie de ma vie et de ma famille mais
Mireille était vraiment ma sœur vraiment
ma sœur etindelon vous continuez à le
voir oui toujours aujourd'hui comment
va-t-il écoutez il va plutôt pas mal on
va dire il va plutôt pas mal je suis
très très proche d'antthony qui me enfin
voilà donc j'ai des nouvelle
régulièrement et avec tout ce qui lui
est arrivé comme truc lamentable il va
plutôt bien oui il va bien effecement
est- est-ce que les choses se calment
les choses se calment B heureusement
puis j'espère que la justice va va
aplanir le tout encore mieux non non il
est dans sa campagne avec ses chiens et
il va plutôt bien entouré de ses enfants
en plus donc ce qui est génial mais ses
enfants qui viennent le voir
régulièrement pour s'assurer que qu'il
aille bien absolument il a passé une
période un peu un peu
difficile question les questions du PAF
alors ça sont les téléspectateurs qui
posent des des questions nous en avons
sélectionné quelquesunes vous allez
répondre Véronique bien sûr première
question
qui va s'afficher sur sur votre écran
laquelle est-ce qu'on vous a déjà
proposé de recommencer l'émission Gy
tonic on nous l'a proposé pardon oui
c'est Thomas qui dit ça excuse-m ah
Thomas alors cher Thomas on l'a pas
proposé vraiment et je trouve que c'est
dommage parce que on pourrait la
moderniser le le souci c'est qu'il faut
quand nous on était deux c'était
vraiment un tandem et c'était ça qui
fonctionnait c'était ça qui fonctionnait
aujourd'hui oui pourquoi pas mais j'ai
plein d'idées en tout cas ah vous oui
s'il y a quelquun qui qui
écoute c'est lancé c'est lancé vous
relverez le dimanche matin pour refaire
pour faire une séquence pourquoi pas
ouais pourquoi pas ouais non mais c'est
c'est superqu pas question numéro 4
quels sont les conseils fitness que vous
donneriez à quelqu'un qui débuterait
aujourd'hui de bien choisir son
professeur de bien choisir son club de
pas les se faire avoir dans des clubs
bidon comme il y a partout et de
s'entourer dans la vie il faut
s'entourer des bonnes personnes donc ça
se on le voit on le REF on le sent et
faire des exercices qui soient pas on va
pas faire de la Gy tonic en rentrant
dans un club le professeur est censé
vous donner des bonnes playlists des
bonnes musiques vous faire travailler
dans le tempo de la musique ce qui est
très important et surtout vous faire
travailler avec un échauffement les
épaules la taille lesou mais si on n pas
les moyens de se payer un coach ou
d'aller dans un club et ben alors on
appelle regard conseil pratique on
regarde l on tape Véronique vous aurez
toutes nos émissions et vous les faites
devant la télé pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
poursuivre mais on peut aller dans le BO
Boulogne on peut aller au champ de Mar
non mais mais pourquoi pas mais moi j'ai
donné des cours au champ de Mar c'est
dans le bois aussi ça c'est si vous êtes
parisien effectivement oui mais partout
il y a des des petits chemins de
campagne partout vous savez ce qu'il
faut que vous fassiez de la
pétanque c'est la meilleure chose au
monde pour la c'est de la stratégie
c'est de la souplesse c'est c'est
extraordinaire moi je fais faire dans
les vill soleil la p ben c'est pas mal
voilà la pét c'est génial ça met tout le
monde d'accord et en plus c'est sympa
merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'ê véroni verci